- [Instructor] We have some
type of study described here.
I encourage you to pause this video,
and think about whether this
is an observational study,
it's an experiment, or
it's a sample study.
And also think about whether
it was conducted well.
All right, now let's do this together.
A group of doctors was
interested in comparing
the effectiveness of
placebo pills and real pills
in treating migraines.
Placebo pills are pills that look
just like the regular pill,
and from a patient's point of view,
they don't know which on they're getting.
The reason why we do this in studies
is because there's something
called a placebo effect.
Often times, just by taking something
that you think is good for you,
some medicine that you
think might help you,
it actually does help you.
We can think about why the
placebo effect happens,
but this is well documented.
So when people are
trying to test medicine,
they wanna say, well,
does this have an effect
above and beyond the placebo effect.
That's why they are
putting them in these two,
that's why they're comparing
the real pills to the placebo pills.
They randomly assigned
a group of 300 patients
suffering from migraines into two groups.
So they have their 300,
they have their 300
patients right over here.
And they're randomly putting
them into the placebo group.
Placebo group, or the real pill group.
One group was given a real pill,
oh no, we already read that.
Both groups were told which
kind of pill they got.
That is sketchy because the
whole point about a placebo
is that you think you got the real thing,
or you think you might
have gotten the real thing.
If you're told you got a placebo,
that tends to undermine
the placebo effect.
If you're just told
you're given a sugar pill,
well, then the impact, well anyway.
This is, that right over there
is definitely bad practice.
So let's keep going over here.
Before taking the pills,
and a day afterwards,
the patients were asked
to fill out questionnaires
regarding their condition.
Then, the doctors analyzed
the overall changes
in questionnaires for each
group and compared them.
All right, so first of all,
what type of study is this?
Well, we're taking our groups,
we are randomly putting them
into two different groups.
You can call the placebo
group maybe the control group.
And then you're putting the real pill
as you're actual experimental group.
So this is a classic experiment.
This is a classic experiment.
You're trying to establish
a causal relationship.
You wanna see whether this real pill
actually makes migraines better.
Migraines better.
So does it actually do it,
and does it actually do
it better than a placebo?
And you're randomly putting
the people in both groups
to try to distribute any
confounding variables
that there might be there.
This is clearly an experiment.
Now the other options,
you might have said,
well, this may be an observational study?
Remember, an observational
study, observational,
that's more of where you
look at a population,
you look at a group,
you ask them a bunch of questions often,
and you see if they're
correlations between two variables.
So variable one, and variable two,
and you're able to make
some type of correlational statement.
You're not trying to get at causality.
In a sample study, a sample study,
this is just you trying
to estimate a parameter
for the entire population.
So a sample study might of been,
of the entire population what
percentage gets migraines.
You can't talk to the entire population,
maybe the entire population
is millions of people,
so you take a sample of say 100 people.
And you ask them, do you get migraines?
Then you say, okay, that
percentage of our sample
that get migraines, that's a good estimate
for the parameter.
What percentage of my entire population
actually gets migraines?
So this was clearly an experiment.
Now the next question is, well,
was this experiment conducted well?
Even when I read it, I was
bothered by both groups
were told which kind of pill they got.
That completely defeats
the purpose of a placebo.
The placebo effect is, hey,
I think I'm taking something
good for me, and it's been
documented that when you
think you're taking a pill that helps you,
it often times does help you.
And so when someone's coming
up with a new medicine,
it better perform, or it
better be more effective
than just that placebo.
I don't like the fact that,
this is a very bad study
to tell both groups
what kind of pill they got.
You actually should tell neither group
which type of pill they got.